thank you
hey kids how was your day I knew the
answer to that question I'd had kind of
a busy day going around solving
everyone's problems I started by going
to see my buddy Stavros the florist
Stavros I assume yes I just wanted to
welcome you to the neighborhood well
thank you yeah I brought you some
sandwiches by the way how good is lamb
huh
oh
gotcha oh
get back in
so sorry is there anything I can do for
you oh no no I
well that's when I realized my kids
didn't understand the concept of killing
with kindness because they'd never seen
it so I decided I'd prove it to them
by going on a hugicidal rampage
is that Reuben Rocking The Potter's
facts quidiculous Hey listen buddy I
heard about Luke calling his teacher
mommy epic fail by the way but you know
since you're one of the cool kids maybe
you could get the other ones to ease off
a little
cool air bump all right Lee it's Phil
Dunphy from down the street we haven't
met I was actually calling to leave a
message for your wife just to say thanks
for hiring my daughter Haley listen we'd
love to have you in the messes over for
a glass of wine or or uh maybe you and I
could go out for a boys night but anyway
if you could damn it
oh
hey Karen Sullivan Alex's dad well look
who's teeth got so nice and straight
who wants to go first are you crazy
one at a time you called Miss Cooper a
man no I didn't I got her husband Lee on
the machine no husband she's Lee weirdly
deep voiced alcoholic daily Cooper who
you invited out for a glass of wine
thanks to a little charm offensive with
Karen one thing did change a better
party I'm not invited ridiculous epic
fail now the whole school is just
laughing at both of us
stop bro say
why not
what
change of plans
this isn't over
I think he's the one standing next to
Matthew no
he's feeling a little under the weather
I let him stay home or is he just too
embarrassed to leave the house why would
he be embarrassed because Dad tried to
fix all our problems and instead ruined
all our lives nightmare you girls are so
dramatic do I need to call you a
wambulance
[Music]
whatever happened with the kids I don't
want you to feel bad about it I don't
I now invite The Godfather and the
Godmother to join us
don't worry I'll take care of everything
tomorrow that may not be necessary my
wife
Phil and Claire as god parents are you
ready to help the parents of this child
in their duties
we are
do you renounce Satan
[Music]
I do without attention
[Music]
and all his works
thank you
I do renounce them hey
hey
and all his empty promises
[Music]
[Applause]
I do renounce them
[Music]
Godfather is it your wish that this
child be baptized
it is
[Music]
in the name of the Father the Son and
the Holy Spirit
what name have you given the child for
hencio Joseph Pritchett
may God be with you all
we're never going to call him that
so I heard that somebody released a
bunch of rats into Karen Sullivan's
party the other night and Lee Cooper's
camper just rolled into her lemon tree
Lucas and everything in Providence
school anymore because Reuben admitted
he made the whole thing up
isn't that crazy how all of our kids
problems just disappeared
don't ever ask me about my business
Claire
what are you talking about
don't ask me about my business I wasn't
good
don't
[Music]